hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
productor your evidence protect yourself
advanced enclosures for forensic labs
because then invite Kelly Williams and
David with Setia
product managers lab Congo corporation I
am Kelly bak of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by laberd's and sponsored by lab
conca for more information on our
sponsor please visit lab conquer calm
jaw let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the after question and click the
send button will answer as many
questions we'll see it's time for at the
end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing this
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab sound at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right of
the presentation window involve the
process to obtain your credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenters
Kelly Williams and David with Setia
Kelly Williams is a product manager for
Firenze forensic lab equipment at lab
cargo corporation Kelly has helped a lot
cargo customers what their application
and equipment needs for more than 17
years she has a BA in biology and an mba
in marketing prior to working with lab
cargo
Kelly kinga conducted endocrinology
research and biochemistry lab David was
sestra is the Kansas city-based product
manager for lab conquer corporation
David manages lab conquers particulate
containment enclosures for
nanotechnology and pharmaceutical
applications although a microbiologist
at heart David has also worked in
pharmaceutical analytical chemistry
other products and David's portfolio
include water purification products
glassware washers and glove boxes
david droid blanco in 2016 kelly you may
now begin your presentation Thank You
Kaylee and thank you for joining us
today we're going to talk about advanced
enclosures in this lab and we have been
involved in a lot of in the planning and
construction and renovation and many new
forensic crime labs all over the country
in the past five years and we thought
today we would share what we are seeing
in these labs and exactly how lab
equipment is changing with the new
demands on them the first trend that
we're seeing in the forensics labs as
far as the equipment and generally in
all labs is the protection of laboratory
personnel is increasing regulations have
increased and as well as people's
awareness about the hazards that are
present in the lab now workers and
people that work in the lab want
protection from these seamless
enclosures for even methods that they
used to have on the open bench so the
attitude is why take the risk when you
don't need to and as a result people are
using more hoods and enclosures and
these when I say enclosures they're like
specialty hoods that are getting more
specialized specific to different
applications another trend that we're
seeing is increase in evidence
protection with DNA being the golden
standard in the courtroom and analytical
equipment in general becoming much more
sensitive it doesn't take much to
contaminate a sample map so evidence is
critical is people do not want to do not
want their evidence to get contaminated
so they're using different ways to
protect their evidence and reduce the
risk of contamination
so other trend the last trend that we're
seeing is the increase in sustainability
this is a huge trend especially when
you're talking new construction or
renovation anytime that someone is
changing the building or the equipment
in the building they're wanting to
reduce the operating cost and become
more environmentally friendly in as a
result sometimes these trends can be in
opposition of each other meaning in
general when you add more fume hoods or
enclosures lots of times they require
the air movement to for that containment
or that protection so in essence you can
increase your operating costs by adding
just standard hoods and not taking in
the sustainability factors into the
equation
common laboratory equipment in forensics
labs our biological safety cabinets VCR
enclosures fume hood evidence drawn
cabinets
see a few chambers fever crit powder
stations and powder containment hoods
the last five items that are highlighted
there are the ones that we're going to
discuss today although we do supply all
of these types of equipment to forensics
lab the first one that I would like to
start with is an evidence drying cabinet
and specifically what is this evidence
drawing cabinet doing in what makes it
safe and effective back in the day a lot
of people used to dry evidence in fume
hoods or they would even have a shower
stall that they would dry evidence in
and as forensic science is advanced so
has a requirement for this drying
procedure and basically what the
evidence drawing cabinet offers over
these shower stalls or fume hoods is
safety generally when you're drawing
evidence it's a biological hazard
because it would it is being dried
because it had body fluids on it or
other liquids that that can make the
body fluids more hazardous so the first
thing that the evidence drawing cabinet
is going to have is a HEPA filter this
helpeth filtered exhaust reduces the
biohazard risk for the rest of the lab
so if you are using a shower stall and
it's just drying there you're not doing
anything with the air that could be
passing over that evidence to protect
the rest of the people in the lab so the
HEPA filter is critical also there is a
carbon filter the carbon filter of
exhaust is mainly there to eliminate
odours so so this exhaust is being both
HEPA filtered and carbon filter
evidence drawing cabinets provide a a
means to lock the cabinet we're going to
maintain our chain of custody if you
just put something in a fume hood it's
very hard to lock that fume hood and
maintain the chain of custody unless you
lock the whole room so being able to
secure your evidence very easily in a in
a cabinet is a nice feature not only do
we want to protect the lab workers from
the bio hazards we also want to protect
the evidence so like I mentioned earlier
the DNA standard being the standard in
the courtroom and the sensitivity of
analysis has made it very critical to
protect that evidence so a cabinet when
operating properly is going to have a
pre-filter to prevent
cross-contamination of that evidence
other things that you need to consider
or because you are putting a biohazard
in a cabinet and then you're going to
need to clean that cabinet you're going
to need to look at the surface of what
that cabinet is made of if it's plastic
or porous you may not get it as clean as
you want or decontaminate it as you want
if you look at other industries such as
medical industry or food industry
they're using stainless steel and that's
what we choose to use in our cabinets we
really feel like this is a very
cleanable surface and one that is the
golden standard for being able to be
decontaminated to aid in that
decontamination we also in some of our
models at a UV light the UV light is for
secondary decontamination and so you
would emit you would clean your cabinet
so but then you would use your UV light
for secondary decontamination what's
really nice about the UV in this
application is that UV denatures DNA so
in evidence we're very concerned about
DNA so being able to assure that you're
putting new evidence into a DNA
three cabinet is a very nice feature to
have
evidence drying cabinets come in a
variety of sizes and you can go anywhere
from a benchtop cabinet up to a five
foot wide cabinet the main thing is that
you're going to want to make sure that
you have enough room to dry the evidence
that you typically see coming into your
lap
it's common for evidence drawing
cabinets to be banked together like
these picture here and it's also very
common for the cabinet to be located
where the evidence is coming into the
building you want to minimize the
movement of the evidence and you want to
get them into a cabinet as soon as
possible so to protect the the building
and the workers in the building but also
to protect that evidence here you will
see that these cabinets are adapted some
cabinets can be our cabinets can be
ejected or non-ducted it just depends on
the preference of the laboratory
like I mentioned earlier when you're
looking for cabinets material as
construction is very important our
cabinets use a stainless steel liner and
not only does this give superior clean
ability but it also does make it very
resistant to the UV light and germicidal
cleaners so you want if you're going to
be purchasing the cabinet you're going
to want a cabinet that will last and
last and so it's very critical that you
look at the materials of construction
like I mentioned earlier having a DNA
free environment is a big plus when
you're processing evidence however you
want to make sure that that DNA cannot
be accidentally the DNA or the UV light
can't be accidentally turned on if you
were to load your samples or evidence
and then turn the UV light on you're
going to denature the DNA that is on
that evidence when designing our
cabinets we thought of this and we made
our UV light require a security lock so
in order to turn the UV light on we do
have a security lock that needs to be
turned on for that UV to work so you
can't accidentally denature the DNA on
your evidence
the next section of the forensics lab
that we like to look at is the latent
print section and in the latent print
section you're going to find a CA or
superglue scheming chambers humid DFO
chambers in your print dusting stations
large sinks bench and tables and you're
also going to want to make sure that
this whole area the Rings themselves
have proper ventilation there's a lot
going on in these rooms and it's boys a
plus start out with the well equipped
room okay the first thing I would want
to address is the CA fuming chambers
pictured right here is an automated CAPM
each chambers we are talking about see a
few chambers in general there is a big
trade-off between the amount of glue you
use the types of glue you use even the
10 that you use the temperature that
you're heating to in assuming time these
are all affect each other so so it's
critical to look at your process and to
make sure that when you adjust one that
you're adjusting the other one to get
great results
that is what's really nice about an
automated viewing chamber because the
different parameters the different
factors that I mentioned greatly affect
each other it's very nice to have an
automated human chamber where you can be
assured that how you ran your fuming
method yesterday is the same as that
you're running it today as the same that
will be running tomorrow getting great
prints is nothing is something that just
doesn't happen
you need to be able to control the
parameters and ensure that you are
getting the high standard results that
you expect
the fuming the automated human chamber
makes this whole process a lot easier
the process you're controlling your
humidity levels you're controlling your
eating you're controlling your exposure
time and your and you are our captcha BT
is the is our human chamber will also
help you automate the ending of the
procedure to ensure that you don't over
fume it
air circulation is a critical process
parameter during the fuming stages
you're going to want to make sure that
your cabinet has great airflow pattern
meaning you don't have hot spots that
the evidence that is closest to the the
fumes being generated get more exposure
than the far corner of the cabinet so
having even air flow patterns during the
humidification the fuming in the exhaust
is very critical to have consistent
results throughout your cabinets
humidity level is is the critical
parameter in the few nice stages it's
important that you can it will make it a
lot easier your humidifier is built-in
and also if it can be calibrated
calibrating both your humidity levels if
your humidifier and your hot plate will
help ensure that you get the standard
repeatable results day after day if your
cabinet does not have a way to calibrate
the humidity level or the temperature
plate you might you want to make sure
that you stay on top of this and take
regular readings and make sure what you
believe to be the same parameters are
really happening
the humidity optimal humidity levels for
fuming is between 70 and 80% humidity so
if you if you are humidifier is drifting
you may not be in that optimal window of
great development it will not only
affect the quality of your self results
but will also affect how easily they can
be disrupted meaning if your humidity
level is not between 70 and 80 percent
it is very easy to smear those prints
that you have developed so when you take
your evidence and put it in the evidence
room there's a there's a good chance
that you could lose that print just in
the handling and the packaging of that
evidence so if you medieval levels that
is consistent is very important
here we are looking at some accessories
when you're picking out a see a few
enchanting and the dimensions when
picking out that cabinet one of the most
common measurements that people measure
or judge their cabinet by is the
diagonal the diagonal measurement is
going to be the longest piece of
evidence that you can put in there so
you want to make sure that your cabinet
has a large area for you to accommodate
the evidence that enters your lab
another thing that you're going to want
to look at is the accessories your
accessories are going to help you
maximize your chamber and also make it
easier to view certain pieces of
evidence when you look when you compare
cabinet to cabinet the size the
dimensions where the controls are what
accessories are available with those
cabinets are all important things to
consider
you
unfortunately cleaning your CH chamber
your CAPM e chamber is going to be
something that you are going to
regularly have to do when you are CH you
me and you get over processing and you
get buildup of the CA deposit on the
cabinet over time what will happen is
the CA will be more attracted to those
deposits than they are to be evident so
over time you're going to have to add
more and more CA to get the same results
in the same great prints that you had
were previously getting and this is a
vicious circle because then that will be
more and more cleaning that you're going
to have to do with your cabinet so it's
critical that these cabinets get cleaned
regularly and one thing that you're
going to want to look at when you're
picking out a cabinet or a chamber is
how easily does a CA come off of that
chamber being able to clean it is
important and and being able to clean it
easily is even more important our
capture BT fuming chamber uses stainless
steel we did testing on it a lot of
different materials and the stainless
steel was the one that was easily clean
the most easily and also it can be
cleaned with just stainless steel
cleaner which happens to put a very thin
coating on the stainless steel that
actually inhibits the CNE deposit so
having a chamber that's easily cleanable
is a big big plus
also when you're looking at cabinets
some of the new things that have been
coming out that people have been worked
on have worked on for years is typically
when people see a fume they give the new
seen staining there's been a lot of
effort going into finding superglue or
modifying superglue so that it will
fluoresce or it will buy that
fluorescence it will eliminate the need
stain afterwards so essentially you're
turning the 2-step fuming and staining
process into a one-step process where
you simply keep you with special glue
and then you can get actually excellent
prints with the luminescence it almost
adds a third dimension where the prints
literally almost pop off the off the
media at you in order to accommodate
these new lose that are that are hitting
the market you need the ability to
adjust your temperature to ranges that
cabinets have not our fuming chambers
have not been to before and you need to
be able to adjust your fuming time so
looking at cat chambers if you have a
chamber that you can program and you can
change the program to to the parameters
that you specifically want that is is a
nice feature to have
here's a picture of those fluorescent
prints using Lumi cyano and you can tell
that they're excellent prints and
they're very very easy to read
you
other factors to consider when you're
getting ca fuming chamber is how easy is
it to use is it repeatable what kind of
flexibility do I have to change the
program for the new glues or techniques
that are coming out because when you buy
this chamber you're going to want to
have it for years and years so being
flexible and being able to accommodate
new things that develop are important
does my chamber prevent overexposure
meaning can I start my cycle walk away
and not have to be worried or be right
be right at the cabinet or chamber when
it when the fuming exhausted or fuming
space is done to ensure that my prints
don't arms overexposed so overexposure
prevention can really great being a
bring a peace of mind maintenance
requirements how easy is it to clean and
maintain what sort of filters what is my
filter life or important questions to
ask and also you want to make sure that
you're whoever you purchase this from
has the ability to support and service
your cabinet you're going to have this
chamber for a really long time so you
want to make sure that that company will
be there to support that product over
those years
another item in the latent-print section
is fume hood and we have seen dramatic
changes in fume hoods over the past 10
years the need to contain has increased
so so people are expecting higher and
higher containment levels while at the
same time they're expecting this
containment to be maintained with less
amounts of air so what has developed or
what they call high-performance fume
hoods an Oracle good old standard fume
hood you will have containment it around
100 feet per minute to be classified as
a high performance fume hood the fume
hood will need to have that think
payment that will need to do it at a
reduced amount of air typically around
60 feet per minute and it doesn't sound
like that big of a difference but right
there by going from 100 feet per minute
to 60 feet per minute you're reducing
the amount of air or tempered air
through that fume hood by about 40%
so if we look at a yearly operating cost
to operate a normal typical normal fume
hood you're looking and it will vary
depending on what area the country you
live in and how much heating and air
conditioning that you have to do to the
air in your laboratory but on average it
costs for a standard fume hood about six
thousand eight hundred and sixty seven
dollars for the operating cost of that
fume hood and that's just and
conditioning the air that is leaving it
if you were to use a high-performance
hood instead of your standard fume hood
in that application your average cost is
around three thousand nine hundred and
twenty so right there in one year you're
saving over three thousand dollars in
one fume hood so you can imagine if you
have a building that has six or eight
hood you can
significally affect your operating cost
yearly operating costs so that is just
one year so you can times that how many
years you think you're going to be in
that building and generally people build
their buildings for a very long time so
it doesn't take very much time for for a
new construction or renovations to get
the payback or the return on that
investment by going for a
high-performance fume hood over a
standard fume hood another area that has
developed to increase sustainability and
provide protection it's filtered fume
hoods and enclosures we are seeing these
become more common in that and in filter
fume hoods you want to make sure that
you are you doing the same application
over over in that fume hood because each
application that is done in a filtered
fume hood should be that what the
processes and the chemicals that are
used in the application should be
analyzed before it is done in that fume
hood you're depending on those filters
to protect your yourself and everyone in
your lab so you want to make sure that
your method and what you're doing is
compatible with those filters so the
filter fume hoods are great ways to
increase sustainability and that safety
factor you just want to make sure that
your application is fitting for that
hood but these enclosures and filter
fume hoods are getting more and more
popular every year another enclosure for
forensics labs that increases
sustainability in reduces operating
costs is the fingerprint powder station
this unique enclosure was designed
specifically for fingerprint powder you
will notice that it has an open design
the in order to allow you to fingerprint
powder large pieces of evidence the
air in this enclosures being drawn down
through the work surface that has a lot
of different holes in it and to the back
of the enclosure the pattern of the work
surface is designed so that you have
equal down airflow throughout the work
surface even if you're in the front or
the back of it you're going to have
equal flow so that's that is very good
in order to capture all the powder this
decreases energy consumption because
you're using a pre-filter and a HEPA
filter so the air that you're pulling
into the enclosure is going right back
into the room so you are not losing air
that you've paid money to temper the
other thing that's great about the
fingerprint powder station is that it
frees up your fume hoods without such an
enclosure people will use a fume hood to
do fingerprint powders and what will
happen is they will get fingerprint
powder all over that hood and no one
else in the lab will want to use that
hood because it will be quite messy once
you get the fingerprint powder behind a
baffle and such it's almost impossible
to clean so this fingerprint powder
station will free up your fume hood for
chemical usage and it will also return
the air to the room
I'm going to turn it over to Dave who is
going to talked about the safe handling
of powders in laboratories great thanks
Kelly so I'm going to talk a little bit
about some of the different options that
are available for containment of
hazardous drug powders no question the
hot topic in forensics lately has been
how to handle opioids that has been
taken out of the field and brought in
for analysis so first thing I'm going to
do is talk a bit about some solutions or
I guess some so common mistakes that are
made in lab and then I'll transition
over to solutions that are out there for
different containments of these
hazardous powders so without further ado
first thing I want to take a look at is
an environment we certainly want to
avoid in a laboratory so here's our
friend al pacino sitting in front of a
bit of a mess on the laboratory bench
and you can imagine if this is your
laboratory it might cause a pretty big
concern reality is though that not all
powders are needing to be in such large
volumes to be hazardous if you have a
mound of powder like this obviously not
great but there are certainly some
extremely potent pharmaceutical powders
that are being seen frequently that can
be much more hazardous and and in very
small quantities so just a quick
analysis of some some bench good and bad
practices so here's a woman who is
working with some powders she's
measuring something out and it looks to
the untrained eye just a quick look ever
TPE
everything looks good she's got she's
got a gloves on she's got a breathing
mask of sorts but if you look a little
bit closer
there are a lot of practices here that
issue were weighing hazardous powers or
measuring hazardous powders out there's
some causes for concern so first thing
first he's on the open bench she's got
her contaminated parts of her containers
over tap the kimwipe a mask that is not
the most ideal filtered mask all of
these are causes for concern in the
laboratory if you're working with
extremely hazardous powders well so if
we move this to a hood and say the thing
behind her there are a couple other
things that are still problematic so not
all hoods are safe and what I mean by
that is there are specific codes for a
specific application Kelly talked about
a few of them so if we looked at just a
typical vented fume hood which is ideal
for handling hazardous chemical vapors
they miss out on a couple of important
details for capturing hazardous drugs so
the first one would be that they're not
filtered with a HEPA filter a HEPA
filter is a high efficiency particulate
air filter that's meant specifically for
capturing hazardous powders in a fume
hood that would not exist a fume hoods
also typically have a higher face
velocity so the airflow moving into the
opening in the enclosure where you're
working is typically going to be quite
high so that means that powers can fly
around readily versus a couple of powder
containment solutions that we'll be
talking about in a bit remember a fume
hoods are designed for capturing aera
gases coming off of chemicals so
definitely a different behavior than a
particulate affiliated with a hazardous
drug powder the other thing that's a big
concern is okay well no filter and a
whole length of ductwork well anything
that I'm going to be weighing or
manipulating that's going to leave the
the
Korea is going to be carried into the
ductwork into the remote blower and then
out onto the rooftop of the the lab
where I'm working which means that if I
ever have to go modify that ductwork or
if there's a leak or if someone's on the
rooftop servicing blower or maybe just
replacing a filter somewhere else for
the building supply air they potentially
could be become exposed to anything that
has escaped from the lab into that
contaminated duct running onto the 'ya
onto the rooftop so you have to think
about not only what you're doing and
where you're taking a handling or your
hazardous materials but where they're
going to be going after they've been
drawn away from where you were working
there's another type of hood that's used
known as a ductless EDD sometimes that
filter fume hood is another terminology
for it and Kelly mentioned these earlier
these are really again common because
they allow for laboratories to protect
themselves without having to tie into an
exhaust system but they are carbon
filtered heads first so a carbon filter
is excellent at containing and absorbing
a number of chemicals vaporous gaseous
chemicals but when it comes to capturing
a hazardous drug particulate such as say
fentanyl they're not really ideal
because they are looking for a gas to be
bound rather than just simply stopping a
particulate so I see a lot of forensic
labs looking for ductless hoods if
you're looking for a ductless and you
want to be sure that it's not just a
carbon filter hood because that will
really not protect you from fentanyl or
other hazardous opiate drugs
if these enclosures do have HEPA filters
typically that filters not going to be
anything more than a simple small small
HEPA filter intended for capturing some
dusts or nuisance particulates certainly
not for use for for hazardous drugs and
in part that's because the HEPA filter
is typically without what's called a
Bagon bag out or di do filter housing
the bagging value out system is in short
of a physical bag that allows you to
remove a HEPA filter from the
contaminated area inside inside a
enclosure so that when you have to go
replace a filter you're not just pulling
out loose dust into the room that might
contain hazardous drugs such as Sentinel
like any other chemical fume hood
oftentimes ductless hoods that run
faster phase velocities which means that
air coming into the enclosure is going
to be turbulent and can potentially
cause them some swirling of particulate
matter back out of the enclosure unlike
with gas which is easily swept to the
back and out through the venting system
so there are a couple of recommended
enclosures for hazardous drug powders
and I'm going to talk about three
different formats of them you see here
just a couple quick pictures of these so
they look like codes or containment
boxes but they have specific
characteristics that benefit capturing
particulates okay so the first PUD
that's typically used to contain
fentanyl is what's called an expert
system which is a type of powder
containment hood these are negative
pressure hoods that work similarly to a
fume hood in the sense that they're
pulling air away from an operator into
the hood and then out through some kind
of exhaust powder containment hoods are
different than fume hoods because they
utilize a HEPA filter and ideally this
HEPA filter should be in a bag in bag
out setup where the powder is going to
be captured on to the filter and it when
it comes time to replace that filter
that process can be done by removing the
filter into a bag rather than just out
into the laboratory a really nice way of
thinking about the bagging bag out
system is if you were to go change your
home furnace filter for your home AC
filter you're going to pull it out and
see all of the contaminants on that
filter well if they were hazardous drugs
ideally you would want to pull them into
a sealed bag and that's what the bag and
bag out process is doing is containment
is separating the contaminated filter of
yourself and the laboratory other
important things about containment
powder enclosures are having air foils
and a baffle that promote turbulent free
air movement and typically you want
these enclosures to be tested by a third
party source to know that these are
effective at containing hazardous
powders so safe bridge is one example of
a company that tests these enclosures
and what you want to look for is data
that represents containment at a level
that's as good or better than what the
operational exposure limit
is of any hazards drug you might be
handling these enclosures are typically
ductless in a sense that they're moving
air back into the laboratory rather than
through exhaust duct work and that's
typically because powders are not giving
off hazardous papers or fumes that are
not desirable to breathe so for a
laboratory to install one of these
products and typically very simple just
setting it on the bench you want to make
sure that you can exhaust these sets as
possible
should your application change and you
require the use of either something
that's a smelly sample or you're using
light duty chemicals such as methanol RS
even nitrile to dilute the product that
you've brought in from the field so a
quick look at how containment is is
promoted by this enclosure design you'll
notice there are several arrows
representing airflow moving from left to
right so left would be where you're
standing on this side view you'll notice
that there are shapes of these air foils
that are promoting airflow into the hood
that are smooth and ensuring lamin arity
or smooth non turbulent airflow which is
important when containing particulates
that can typically have a very light
mass and may easily escape an enclosure
that is turbulent
in some cases it's desirable to have a
second HEPA filter if you're concerned
with maybe a extremely potent hazardous
compound
maybe car fentanyl soup fentanyl
something that's not easily controllable
you know and you have workplace concerns
about its containment the second HEPA
filter can help alleviate some of those
concerns so here this view is showing
the front panel off of a double HEPA
filtered enclosure and you can see the
yellow bags which are the Bagon Bagon
systems which help when removing either
filter should it become contaminated
during a loading over the course of
several years another enclosure that is
is sometimes used for fentanyl or a
hazardous powder containment is a glove
box this is simply a sealed chamber that
provides a complete physical barrier
between yourself and the product that
you're sampling for testing in this case
you're going to be working through
clothes there's a transfer chamber that
should always exist on these types of
enclosures that allows for an
intermediate pass through into the
device and these utilize HEPA filters or
sometimes ulpa filters their goal is to
trap powders from escaping to the
glovebox
but again allowing workers to handle in
a sealed
contained system when it comes time to
change out HEPA filters you again want
to make sure that your isolation
glovebox is going to have a bag in bag
out process for changing those filters
and that's just important to make sure
that you don't expose the laboratory to
these hazardous powders that you've been
working with inside this containment
chamber so
those are a couple of quick ways to
address fentanyl or hazardous powder
containments and at this time I want to
just reiterate that we've got some time
set aside for Kelly and I both to answer
questions on our various hoods and
fingerprinting stations and fentanyl
containment devices so thanks so much
for attending and looking forward your
questions
you
Thank You Kelly and David for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left of your screen well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is we are handling large
packages of evidence that may contain
benda till fentanyl use me what
enclosure should we use
a great question so so a lot of times in
laboratories
you know the volumes are really small
maybe a milligram up to a gram but what
do you do if you take a big package of
hazardous powder into your laboratory
well the the biggest thing you want to
make sure is that it will fit and do it
enclosure so it's important to consider
that when looking at hood make sure
you've got enough size but if you're
dealing with a really large package that
might contain a huge volume of fentanyl
definitely might be a consideration to
move into a glove box because you never
know what's going to happen if you open
that box sometimes you can generate
powders and they might be able to
overcome the the speed of air flowing
into a hood so a glove box can be a good
way to completely seal off and isolate
yourself from a large volume of
hazardous drugs
thank you the next question we have says
we are currently using a closet to dry
evidence and it works fine why should we
use a drying cabinet I'll go ahead and
take that question and that's a good
question
and I do know that evidence was dried in
closets or rooms or even shower stalls
for for quite a fight many years the
first a while ago but what makes an
evidence drying cabinet better than a
closet is a protection that's giving to
more evidence and to you when you put
evidence in a closet that's a biohazard
so if it's dripping with stuff it's
pretty hard to ensure that your closet
is completely clean because of the
different processes that could be in the
closet or that type of stuff the other
thing is is that an evidence drying
cabinet includes a HEPA filter so the
air that's coming out of there's HEPA
filter we're in a closet especially when
you open the door and that kind of stuff
can be exposed so protecting your
evidence and you it is done more
effectively in an evidence drying
cabinet our cabinets do have stainless
steel so you can MD combat and UV light
denature any DNA that's left around or
biohazards
so it's going to denature any viruses or
bacteria that were in that blood or body
fluid that is then in room that that can
harm you but excellent question
Thank You Kelly our next question says
can we modify our current fume hood to
use less air fume hood can not be
modified to become high-performance or
useless there a high performance hood is
designed to contain why using less air
your typical fume hood
does require a certain phase velocity in
order for containment but so if you
lower that phase velocity you're not
going to be guaranteed containment in
that hood unless you test it in that
hood has been designed specifically to
contain with less airflow so it's a lot
more complicated than it seems than just
using less air there's a big trade off
and safety is definitely something that
you do not want to mess with so you need
to use the phase velocity of your fume
hood that it's been read it for
okay and we have time for one more
question in this last one asks do we
need to exhaust a fence until
containment hood to the outside of our
building
great question so if you're venting a
hood to the outside typically it's
because you've got something that's
smelly or you've got a chemical that
that needs to be vented to the outside
that can't be breeze or recirculated
back into the room fentanyl and most
drug powders but selves are not volatile
and don't give off gaseous chemicals
which would not be trapped at at the
filter the powders themselves would be
though so in most cases a HEPA filtered
enclosure that's just recirculating to
the room is acceptable however many
analysis techniques for for small
molecule drugs like fentanyl require
dilution into some kind of solvent as a
primary step so whether that's methanol
or a seeded nitrile based or some other
solvents most often those are you know
being worked with in volumes that are
generating enough volatile hazardous
chemical to to need to duck that outside
so best thing to do is analyze the steps
that you're going to take to analyze
whatever hazardous drug you're working
with and if it includes a gaseous or
vaporous volatile chemical that would
traditionally be exhausted in a fume
hood the answer is that you very likely
need to exhaust the hood that you're
using for fentanyl analysis
you
thank you again David and thank you as
well Kelly do either of you have any
final comments for our audience
No thank you for joining us today and if
you have any questions or if there's any
equipment that we we can help you with
don't hesitate to contact us we get
emails and call all day long from people
with specific questions so we would be
happy to help
before we go I'd like you think the
audience Oh
before we go I would like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
are not have time for today or those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor lab
Congo for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through December of
2018 labret swiller you via email when
it is available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye